for years General Abdul Rahman chiani
led a guard their protected niger's
president Muhammad bazoom he's now
unseated him and replaced him the
self-appointed leader has dissolved
Nigeria's constitution in an exclusive
interview with Al Jazeera a presidential
advisor says chani is jeopardizing more
than politics
so far blood has not been shed but the
statements of the coup leader are
dangerous and can aggravate the
situation more will begin to question
the legality of recruiting hundreds of
soldiers this may lead to an outbreak of
an ethnic conflict the people of Niger
reject the military coup and mostly
support president Muhammad bazoom
supporter
preteritary intervention will lead to
chaos
the International Community says it's
here for us we don't want them here we
don't want its moral lessons it's no
longer credible in the eyes of Africans
tiani's self-appointment came after
chaos and demonstrations gripped the
capital near me after Wednesday's coup
crowd set fire to cars and buildings
near the headquarters of bazoom's party
two years into his presidency
demonstrators say that the
post-president didn't do enough Sunday
school
I agree with chiani I've spent a lot of
time criticizing the mismanagement of
security and the presence of foreign
forces in our country their presence is
more about diplomacy but it's of little
use
many Western allies disagree they insist
Niger needs military support from the
U.S and France to fight the expansion of
armed groups who linked to Al-Qaeda and
isil
Niger may have a new leader but its
political uncertainty still looms across
the West African region Katia Lopez Al
Jazeera